in 1788 as the Constitution was being  debated James Madison wrote that the  chief restraint preventing Congress from  passing laws that apply to the people  but not to Congress is the vigilant and  manly spirit which actuates the people  of America a spirit which nourishes  freedom if this spirit shall ever  diminish so as to tolerate a law not  obligatory on the legislature the people  will be prepared to tolerate anything  but Liberty today we Americans live  under many laws that do not apply to  elected officials and those who work for  them this we hope to preserve Liberty we  must recall to Veit the freedom-loving  spirit of our founding fathers learn  more about the Constitution at  Constitution minute calm  [Music]